[Musique]
salut à tous c'est christophe pour la
chronique politique dans une précédente
vidéo je vous ai présenté l'histoire du
néoconservatisme aux états unis et je
vous ai indiqué également que cette
histoire américaine pouvait nous aider à
comprendre les conflits qui ont cours
actuellement au sein de la gauche
française notamment autour des théories
postmoderne de l'immigration ou de la
place de l'islam au sein de la
république
pourtant si on s'intéresse réellement
aux néo conservatisme américain au
contexte historique qui l'a vu naître à
ses ennemis la nouvelle gauche et l'urss
si on s'intéresse à tout cela et qu'on
essaie de séparer ce qui relèverait d'un
contexte purement américain de ce qui
relèverait d'une forme d'essence et bien
dans ce cas on peut produire grille de
lecture qui peut nous aider à comprendre
comment des clivages émergent au sein
des différentes gauche occidentale avant
de nous pencher sur le cas français il
nous faut donc tout d'abord essayer de
comprendre qu'elle peut être cette
essence du néo conservatisme
voici donc mon analyse personnelle pour
moi le néoconservatisme c'est d'abord la
défense des valeurs classiques du parti
contre un ennemi intérieur partie ici
entendue au sens large la mouvance la
sphère qui regroupe tous ceux qui
adhèrent un courant d'idées
aux etats unis c'est d'abord la défense
contre la dérive de la gauche classique
qui devient de plus en plus
interventionniste via les programmes
sociaux et la discrimination positive
c'est le combat initial interne à la
sphère démocrate au début des années 60
menés dans ce public interest et
commentary puis dans les années 65 73
s'y ajoutent la défense de la gauche
traditionnelle contre les idées de la
new left
il s'agit d'une guerre culturelle sur ce
qu'est le progrès son champ d'action
l'économie la famille ou bien les moeurs
et sur quelles entités et identités
collectives doivent à la fois être
moteur est bénéficiaire de ce progrès on
a une gauche sociale tourner vers les
classes populaires et les syndicats
opposés à une nouvelle gauche tourner
vers les questions sociétales liées aux
identités culturelles raciale sexuelle
etc
ensuite le néoconservatisme c'est la
défense des valeurs de la patrie contre
un ennemi intérieur
la nouvelle gauche mais surtout contre
un ennemi extérieur l'urss véritable
ennemi civilisationnel portant un projet
de société diamétralement opposé à celui
des usa
cet ennemi civilisationnel peut
d'ailleurs s'allier ou trouver des
relais au sein de la noue
gauche son relativisme sa contestation
des valeurs américaines ou le refus de
la guerre du vietnam sont de fait une
forme de soutien au monde communiste
ces deux combats contre la dérive de la
gauche est contre l'ennemi extérieur
sont idéologiquement indissociables aux
usa la gauche qu'ils défendent et
libérale au sens classique
quant à l'idéal américain il repose sur
l'american dream
le mythe du self made man la
méritocratie et l'égalité des chances un
idéal résumé par le fameux droit à la
liberté et à la recherche du bonheur
dont parle la constitution il s'agit
d'un mythe libéral leur valeur partisane
recoupent donc en grande partie les
valeurs fondatrices du système politique
est censé faire largement consensus au
sein du spectre politique
les valeurs de gauche et nationales
qu'ils défendent sont tellement proches
qu'il est parfois difficile de savoir
pour lesquels ils combattent à l'instant
t
pourquoi sont ils opposés aux programmes
sociaux ou à la discrimination positive
parce qu'ils sont américains et croient
aux valeurs américaines de méritocratie
ou parce qu'ils sont de gauche et croit
à d'autres mécanismes de progrès sociaux
sûrement un peu des deux et puis le
néoconservatisme se caractérise aussi
par un phénomène rare le passage d'un
bord à l'autre retournement d'alliance
partisane quand il a été clair que la
gauche était trop molle face à l'ennemi
extérieur
les néo conservateurs se sont tournés
temporairement vers reggane puis quand
le combat au sein de la gauche dans
l'est définitivement perdu certains
comme jane kirk patrick ont
définitivement tourné républicains
puisque la bataille en interne était
perdu que les valeurs du parti n'était
pas sauvable ils ont décidé qu'il
fallait au moins sauver les valeurs de
la patrie en faisant alliance avec ceux
qui les défendent est encore au final
une fois dépouillé de ses spécificités
américaine pour moi on peut résumer le
néo conservatisme de la façon suivante
qu'il s'agit dans un premier temps d'une
défense des valeurs classiques du parti
face à des dérives ou des innovations
idéologique
c'est ensuite une défense des valeurs de
la patrie contre un ennemi
civilisationnel extérieur qui peut
d'ailleurs s'allier avec l'ennemi
intérieur
cette double défense partisane et
patriote s'explique par la proximité
entre l'idéologie partisane des
néoconservateurs et les valeurs qui font
globalement consensus qu'au sein du
spectre politique qui sont fondatrices
du système à la longue ce double combat
entraîne un retournement d'alliance au
profit de la droite un renoncement aux
idées du parti pour pouvoir créer une
nouvelle alliance permettant au moins de
sauver leurs cousines les valeurs
nationales
on renonce à cette petite patrie
intellectuelle qu'est le parti pour
sauver la grande patrie au final le
néoconservatisme exprime une sorte de
combat existentiel pour les valeurs
maintenant voyons la gauche française
mais avant d'appliquer cette grille de
lecture à la gauche de notre pays il
faut d'abord voir l'historique de
l'affrontement entre les différents
partis keira force être dans
l'immédiateté
on a tendance à résumer le conflit entre
d'un côté une gauche sociale et de
l'autre une gauche sociétale
or si on veut réellement regarder la
chronologie on s'aperçoit que l'épithète
des eaux réac où l'accusation de dérive
vers la droite sont largement antérieure
à l'apparition de cet antagonisme tout
d'abord donc petite chronologie de
l'affrontement
une première fracture commencent à
apparaître à gauche au début des années
2000 autour des questions liées à
l'immigration la laïcité l'islam les
banlieues ce clivage est matérialisée en
2002 par la sortie d'un livre qui fera
beaucoup de bruit intitulé le rappel à
l'ordre
enquête sur les nouveaux réactionnaires
ce livre met en garde contre ce qui est
vu par l'auteur comme une dérive du
débat politique en france et alerte
entre autres sur le décalage vers la
droite de certains intellectuels de
gauche
parmi ces personnalités de gauche
attaque et on trouve finkielkraut et
marcel gaucher marcel gaucher est peu
connu du grand public mais c'est une
figure importante dans les débats
intellectuels en france mais la première
déchirure publique a lieu en 2004 lors
des débats sur la loi interdisant le
voile à l'école
les partisans du voile se trouvent
surtout à l'extrême gauche au sein de
laquelle on commence à voir à cette
occasion apparaître la future mouvance
des colonials qui assimile cette loi à
du racisme
la gauche socialiste se lâche
indigéniste cristallise après cet
épisode avec l'appel des indigènes de la
république en 2005 puis donnera
naissance plus tard ou parti des
indigènes de la république
la même année des émeutes éclatent en
banlieue après la mort de zyed et bouna
deux jeunes morts électrocutés en fuyant
la police à partir de là de 2005 à 2010
la figure de l'immigré commencent à
remplacer massivement celle du prolo ou
plutôt les deux figures fusionnent
conduisant à une ethnicisation du social
un pauvre et forcément immigrés et
l'immigré est forcément pauvre pour
l'extrême gauche ce virage permet de
trouver un prolétariat de substitution
et pour la gauche réformiste de trouver
de nouveaux réservoirs de voix ces
virages favoriseront plus tard
l'implantation des théories des
colonials qui viendront les justifier
idéologiquement tout en se considérant
certaine catégorie 1000
tante issus de l'immigration ou
revendication identitaire ainsi assez
significativement
on passe progressivement de
l'acceptation du voile prenons de
l'inclusion de tout dans l'école à
l'acceptation du voile comme libertés
individuelles cet intérêt pour les
catégories issus de l'immigration se
traduit par exemple au npa par la
création de commissions quartier et par
la présentation en 2010 d'une candidate
voilée générant des remous en interne
mais le clivage va définitivement
cristallisé autour des théories
postmoderne apporter des usa qui se
développe massivement au sein des
universités et des milieux militants
surtout à partir des années 2012 c'est
l'émergence de ces théories qui va
donner l'impression d'un clivage entre
gauche sociale et gauche sociétale
en fait c'est l'arbre qui cache la forêt
la gauche a toujours été porté sur le
sociétal le féminisme ou la question des
droits des minorités ne date pas d'hier
en fait la différence entre les
postmodernes uns et les autres au delà
des revendications qui peuvent paraître
de plus en plus nul une heure chez les
post moderne se fait sur les questions
théoriques
cette théorie post moderne qu'on appelle
aussi poste structuraliste ou encore
fraîche théorise ont une histoire
intéressante elle s'appuie sur des
philosophes français de gauche des
années 60-70 qui ont exporté leur
concept aux usa où elles ont été
digérées et nous reviennent en ce moment
sous la forme d studies et de diverses
théories de lutte contre diverses aux
pressions les french theory partent du
principe qu'au vu des catastrophes
politiques des 19e et 20e siècles
le projet politique émancipateur des
lumières et l'universalisme ont échoué
et pour continuer ce projet émancipateur
plutôt que de créer de grandes
idéologies se concentre sur l'idée que
le pouvoir à combattre est partout la
société est un lieu où règnent des
micros pouvoir qui oppresse et impose
une conduite normative transposer à
l'action politique toute réalité
majoritaire devient un discours normatif
et oppressif et toute relation sociale
devient une domination est donc tout
combat contre une norme devient une
lutte de libération légitime et toutes
ces luttes se valent puisque chacune à
sa façon attaque la vision majoritaire
exit la centralité de la lutte des
classes et bienvenue à la non
réalisation des luttes et relativisme
culturel l'universalisme est en vue lui
aussi comme une forme de domination
occidentale incarné en particulier par
l'homme blanc 6 joueurs et héros de fait
la gauche française des années 2010
lutte à peu près contre la même vision
du monde que les
aux conservateurs américains dans les
années 60 70 la seule différence est que
les ide et postmoderne des années 2010
sont plus élaborés idéologiquement
maintenant revenons à nos moutons tout
s'accélère à partir de 2012 avec le
retour de la gauche au pouvoir et donc
avec la possibilité de faire passer dans
la loi ces nouvelles idées très vite
nous annonce une loi sur le mariage gay
à gauche les premiers à avoir contesté
ces revendications post modernes sont
les intellectuels gravitant autour de la
revue le débat une revue de centre
gauche gauche républicaine peu connu
mais importante dans le débat politique
et intellectuelle en france est dirigée
par marcel gaucher la revue a publié un
numéro axée autour de la contestation du
mariage gay et de l'homoparentalité
cette prise de position a valu à marcel
gaucher une pétition contre sa
participation au rendez vous de
l'histoire de blois dont le thème était
les rebelles l'argument des
pétitionnaires menée par le sociologue
d'extrême gauche geoffroy de lagasnerie
était qu'il était trop réac pour parler
de rébellion on peut aussi citer jean
pierre le goff proche de gauche et
maoïstes dans sa jeunesse à l'origine du
concept de gauchisme culturel qui a pris
position contre le mariage gay sur des
arguments anthropologique plus que
morrow pour lui il faut des institutions
sociales pour assurer la stabilité de la
société et le mariage fait partie de ces
institutions à partir de 2014 les idées
post moderne commence à s'implanter
largement de l'extrême gauche jusqu'à
l'ailé gauche du parti socialiste
dans ces années là on voit aussi
apparaître un nouveau phénomène des
personnalités de gauche critique de ces
dérives idéologiques commence à trouver
un écho dans les sphères de droite
surtout à travers le figaro par exemple
à partir de 2014
laurent bouvet chercheur à la fondation
jean jaurès inventeur du concept d'
insécurité culturel ou jean pierre le
goff n'y sont plus interviewé en tant
qu'expert sociologue ou politologues
comme cela pouvait être le cas avant
mais en tant que personnalité de gauche
critique de la gauche et ainsi son
traité en ami
et puis arrive 2015 et les attentats
islamistes des 9/10 et en janvier qui
vont définitivement acté la scission
intellectuelle des gauches jusque là les
indigéniste surtout représentée par le
parti des indigènes de la république
était une sphère particulière dont
beaucoup se méfier après les attentats
au nom de la lutte contre l'islamophobie
ses idées gagnent toute la gauche dure
une partie refuse de condamner ces
attentats car cela risquerait de faire
le jeu de l'islamophobie
une manif touche pas à mon prophète a
même lieu mêlant extraits de gauche et
islamistes
au nom de la lutte contre l'islamophobie
certains vont même aller
participé en mars 2015 un meeting aux
côtés de l'islam politique
en réaction à ce climat laurent bouvet
lance le printemps républicains visant à
défendre la laïcité et les idées
républicaines conséquences des attentats
ou de la montée des idées post moderne
michel onfray le philosophe étiqueté
libertaire donne une interview au figaro
dans laquelle il effectue une sorte de
tournant républicain prélude à sa future
orientation souverainiste républicaine
suscitant une vive polémique à gauche
dans un style plus populaires signe
qu'il faut mettre un nom sur cette
nouvelle gauche devenu incontournable
le terme américains de sj w pour social
justice warriors apparaît sur les
réseaux sociaux pour désigner nos
gauchistes postmoderne
au delà de cette anecdote on peut
estimer qu'à la fin du quinquennat
hollande est théorique postmoderne a
triomphé dans toute la gauche de la
gauche
toutes les organisations sont touchés
tout comme les laboratoires de sciences
sociales ce qui fait naître des conflits
au sein de ceux-ci et depuis 2010 est
devenu hégémonique
notre nouvelle gauche se sent pousser
des ailes et se radicalise tentative de
censure d'une pièce de charb
perturbations de pièces de théâtre jugés
racistes par les organisations
racialiste revendications sur l'écriture
inclusive camp et festival des coloniaux
interdit aux blancs combat contre
l'islamophobie aux côtés de l'islam
politique etc
les pratiques communautaristes
rétrograde se trouve même valoriser
ainsi à l'été 2010 8 on voit le burqini
apparaître sur des plages le npa
organise alors en urgence une
manifestation de soutien à ce vêtement
religieux
face à tout cela notre gauche
conservatrice multiplient les mises en
garde contre l'islam
le communautarisme l'immigration voire
comme ou frais ou finkielkraut contre la
mort de la civilisation occidentale
autant de prises de position vu comme
une droitisation des intéressés mais la
réaction collective peine à s'organiser
certains de nos intellectuels ont publié
une pétition contre l'influencé des
théories des colonials au sein du monde
universitaire laurent bouvet et son
printemps républicain polémique sur
twitter quelques intellectuels s'épanche
dans des médias de droite à coup de
petites phrases polémiques spécialité de
finkielkraut et c'est à peu près tout
après ce petit rappel partiels mais qui
résume l'essentiel
essayons de comprendre cette histoire
française à travers notre grille de
lecture néo conservatrice et commençons
par le commencement
d'abord la défense des valeurs
traditionnelles du parti face à un
ennemi interne
le conflit autour de la redéfinition des
entités collectives qui porte et
sensible du progrès j'ai cristallise en
france autour de deux points les
questions lgbt et immigrés ces deux
grandes catégories viennent remplacer
les classes populaires dans le discours
de la nouvelle gauche française les
théories postmoderne venant avec un peu
de retard justifier ce changement de
cible et d'acteur central du progrès ce
changement débouche sur une remise en
question du socle de valeurs la laïcité
par exemple d'éléments indispensables à
l'émancipation du fait religieux devient
dans l'esprit de la nouvelle gauche une
arme de discrimination anti musulman
ensuite on a aussi une défense des
valeurs de la patrie en france le mythe
politique fondateur de notre système
politique est axée autour des valeurs de
la révolution de 1789 et des lumières
et comme aux usa il est souvent
difficile de séparer ces valeurs
républicaines ou nationales des valeurs
spécifiques à la gauche néo
conservatrice quand ils se battent pour
la laïcité
laurent bouvet et son printemps
républicains se bat at il pour les
valeurs républicaines ou de gauche un
peu des deux ils défendent à ses valeurs
républicaines d'abord contre la gauche
post moderne dont les fondements
théoriques même en sont la réfutation
et puis ensuite contre un ennemi
extérieur ce n'est jamais dit comme ça
mais l'islam est perçu comme un ennemi
civilisationnel c'est un ennemi
civilisationnel plus diffus de l'urss
pour les usa mais il remet tout de même
en question fondamentalement le mode de
vie de notre société républicaine
par exemple les définitions de la
liberté sont diamétralement opposées le
voile est un signe d'oppression pour les
uns et une liberté pour les autres ou
encore ce qui relève de la liberté
d'expression pour les uns est une
insulte à la religion pour les autres
cet ennemi extérieur peut d'ailleurs
s'allier à l'ennemi intérieur pour
combattre les valeurs de la république
et de la gauche classique donnant ainsi
naissance au fameux l'islamo gauchisme
et puis on peut aussi se poser la
question du renversement d'alliance en
france c'est plus confus qu aux usa mais
on peut tout de même noter que certains
néo conservateurs ont un accès plus
facile et fréquent à des médias de
droite que de gauche par exemple laurent
bouvet alain finkielkraut ou encore jean
pierre le goff ont plus souvent droit à
des interviews à des tribunes dans le
figaro que dans libé ou le monde c'est
aussi le cas plus récemment de georges
kiejman oric ancien cadre de la france
insoumise de tendance républicaine et
souverainistes ayant quitté le parti fin
2018 en dénonçant sa dérive
d'hygiéniste il était le seul cadre de
la france un soumise régulièrement
invités aux émissions du figaro et son
départ du parti n'a pas freiné ses
apparitions sur le média de droite bien
au contraire
son positionnement lui a permis d'être
reconnu comme que fréquentable par la
droite puisque défendant le socle de
valeurs nationales également une
question se pose pour delà de l'alliance
médiatique
peut-on assister un basculement massif à
droite ou plus simplement à une alliance
temporaires dans les urnes comme ça a
été le cas aux états unis
avec la mondialisation une grande partie
de la droite molle a mis de côté les
valeurs républicaines dont l'incarnation
à droite était le gaullisme au profit du
libéralisme
résultat ces valeurs ont été investis
par le rassemblement national et il est
difficile d'imaginer des notables de
gauche comme laurent bouvet michel
onfray natacha polony appelé à voter
pour lui alors vous me direz certains
très rares ont sauté le pas comme le
jeune andrea kottaras qu ancien de la
france un soubise qui a rallié le
rassemblement national
c'est vrai et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça
qu'en france à mon avis il faut
distinguer un néoconservatisme rester à
gauche et un néoconservatisme basculer à
droite comme c'est le cas pour qu tarak
catégorie dans laquelle on peut aussi
inclure elisabeth lévy de causeur la
démographe michèle tribalat voir alain
finkielkraut
la différence se fait sur les valeurs
défendues les néo conservateurs de
gauche défendent des valeurs
républicaines
quand les néo conservateurs de droite
vont plus loin en affirmant que ces
valeurs mais aussi notre société ou un
socle civilisationnel particulier la
civilisation occidentale de racine
grecque ou romaine et de culture
chrétienne et qu'au delà des idées
républicaines
ce sont ces valeurs l'histoire et la
société occidentale qui va avec
qu'il faut défendre face à l'ennemi
civilisationnel représenté par l'islam
mais aussi pour les néo conservateurs de
droite par l'immigration
extra-européenne qu'il ne faut pas juste
réguler et intégré mais stoppé et voilà
comment à partir d'une histoire
américaine
on peut produire une grille d'analysé
pour comprendre un phénomène français et
mettre un peu de cohérence entre des
parcours individuels
j'espère que cette interprétation vous
aura paru pertinentes et qu'elle vous
aidera à comprendre les conflits qui ont
cours actuellement à gauche également
une dernière précision dans la vidéo
d'introduction de ce cycle sur le
néoconservatisme je vous indiquais que
je me considérais comme étant
néoconservateurs selon la grille de
lecture que je vous ai présenté
aujourd'hui il faut préciser que je me
considère comme étant néo conservateurs
de droite aussi de temps en temps je
vous ferai des vidéos revenant sur mon
parcours et
frais par des réflexions qui petit à
petit on menait de l'extrême gauche à
des positions beaucoup plus à droite sur
pas mal de sujets jusqu'à envisager des
alliances possibles avec la droite de la
droite et que vous soyez de gauche ou de
droite
j'espère que ces vidéos vous apporteront
matière à réflexion c'est à peu près
tout ce que j'avais à vous dire pour
aujourd'hui
si cette vidéo vous a intéressé
n'hésitez pas à la partager et à vous
abonner à la chaîne si vous la
découvrirez et sur ce je vous dis à la
prochaine